speaking of disoriented i want to play
for you clips of a visibly disoriented
sarah palin now you might remember that
sarah palin was the late john mccain's
vice presidential running mate back in
2008
thankfully they lost and she was kind of
like the opening of the door to
cartoonish trumpism where like anything
goes in some way palin was the
predecessor to people like trump madison
cawthorne marjorie trader greene lauren
beaubert herschel walker as we saw
the normalization of people in
completely over their heads in politics
she recently lost her election trying to
become a congresswoman representing
alaska in the house of representatives
of washington dc she recently lost that
and she appeared on the steve bannon
real america's voice
war room pandemic show
whatever that is
and she seems to be completely
disoriented she doesn't know what the
hell is going on she attacks ranked
choice voting
it's completely wild and this was a
woman who was almost a heartbeat away
from the presidency of the united states
think about that well you called it
steve when you explained what this new
fangled cockamamie system
called ranked choice voting is all about
when it doesn't matter if you perhaps
are the most popular or most qualified
candidate uh no it
you can get a whole lot of votes steve
but if you don't get enough second or
third rankings from voters who choose
another candidate
listening to sarah palin explain ranked
choice voting is absolutely delightful
in that she has no idea what's going on
she doesn't even understand the system
under which she lost
she just has no idea what it's even
about
it
you can get a whole lot of votes steve
but if you don't get enough second or
third rankings from voters who choose
another candidate right then you're
eliminated or then you get second place
and you don't win and it's complicated
you explained it best president trump
explained it very well yeah trump really
explained this concept well he also
explained you know thermodynamics really
well just like she would i'm sure rally
that he had up here
warning alaskans that this newfangled
experiment
with ranked choice voting will split
votes it will allow liberals to skip on
in which is exactly what's happened thus
far they can just skip on in and vote by
the way this was trump's explanation for
rank choice voting fraud
fraud
fraud
it's a fraud that that was his brilliant
explanation and um it's a it's a very
very uh potentially fraught with fraud
she has no idea to this day why and how
she lost she genuinely has no clue um
and then of course she
these people want to use anger they need
everybody to be angry that's how they
operate and here is sarah palin in this
same interview and by the way why sarah
palin's homes are like the most echoey
places ever it's like a cave i i've
never understood but here's sarah palin
in her echoey house
saying people should be angry she lost
that harms the entire nation so i think
the entire country should be angry at
what's going on with this establishment
system and it was the political
establishment that created this system
with the rank choice voting and without
encouraging the other republican to drop
out once he got them three times others
should be outraged about what's going on
here right
our system is harming the rest of the us
the uh everything everything that has a
bad outcome to these people is
fraudulent and um it's sort of the same
argument that they would make if we
figured out a way to get rid of the
electoral college and just have a
national popular vote which we should we
obviously should uh they would say oh
that's harming the country really how is
it how would it harm the country that
the candidate with the most votes wins
well it's not the will of the founder
it's the exact same type of thing if the
system leads to me losing it's a bad
system and sarah palin
there's almo there is something comedic
about the fact that she doesn't even get
how and why she lost and there's an
amazing video from election night a
couple weeks ago
where
she's
like wherever her watch party her
results party is
and the information starts coming in
that she lost and she doesn't even
really get it and at one point she goes
over and she cuts a cake and just the
absurdity the visual absurdity of she
doesn't really know what's going on but
they do have a cake there and she's
gonna move on to the cake it is really
something to see
they don't have any clue what's
happening and there are a number of
systems in this country that should be
reformed
and our voting systems are some of them
and we have to realize that even if they
were to be changed you would then deal
with years of confused people claiming
that by virtue of the fact that they
lost it must be a bad system and
certainly sarah palin is buying into
that full speed ahead
let's talk about vpn's virtual private
networks even if you're using incognito
mode on your browser if you're not using
a vpn everything you do online can be
recorded by your internet provider and
that is permanent because they're
selling it search engines social media
companies are also tracking your every
move you only need one thing to protect
yourself from all of it private internet
access one of our sponsors it's a vpn
it's simple you take a moment and you
download it you turn it on and you're
protected and you stay protected and
that's it vpns can also keep your
connection secure from hackers important
every time you check your bank account
or 401k or pension otherwise it can all
be out in the open private internet
access never records or stores user data
they've even proven this policy multiple
times in court their software is open
source to show that there's no data
being logged
this transparency is why private
internet access is the vpn i use and my
audience gets 82 off so you can stay
protected for just two dollars and 11
cents a month plus you'll get three
months free go to private internet
access dot com slash pacman the link is
down below